- Alright everybody,
we have hit that part of the show
when I deliver you good
news from the interwebs.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat keyboard music)
(audience cheers)
This story begins when a young girl
here in Southern California
discovered that hotels tossed
their linens in the trash
when there's the smallest imperfection.
Things like pin marks
or lipstick residue -
lipstick residues, alright.
(audience laughs)
Sorry.
So she set out to put
those linens to good use.
She launched a nonprofit that collects
the gently used bedding and towels,
and delivers them to
places that can use them,
including homeless shelters,
veterans organizations,
and animal shelters.
In the past six years,
she and her hundreds of student volunteers
have kept more than 45,000
items out of landfills.
Thank you.
From Linens N Love,
let's say hi to Vivian everybody!
(audience applauds)
Hi Vivian!
- Hi Kelly!
- Oh my gosh.
First of all - I love your dimple, Vivian,
and your name.
That little dimple is adorable.
Tell us more about how
this all got started.
- Yeah, so when I was younger,
my dad worked at a motel near Disneyland
and my sister and I spent a lot of time
using the motel linens
to make pillow forts,
or play super competitive
hide and go seek.
So one day my dad told us the
story behind these linens,
and basically these linens were discarded
if they don't meet hotel standards.
And even worse,
they were being sent to landfills
which is definitely not
good for our environment.
So my sister and I
approached the management
of different hotels and
they were very, very kind
to supply us with gently used towels,
blankets, sheets, and even pillows.
So that's basically how
Linens N Love was born.
- [Kelly] That's amazing!
(audience applauds)
And it also,
it's not only helpful for
people that need them,
but also keeping all that
waste out of landfills.
It's just, it's amazing.
It's very eco-friendly, I love it.
This has grown into
something huge though, right?
- Yeah. Yeah, it has.
It's been very, very exciting.
So we started the nonprofit
as just two sisters,
ages 12 and 14,
back in 2014.
But here we are today with
500 student volunteers
and 35 chapters across 15 countries -
including here in the US,
Canada, Singapore, and so much more.
And ultimately our goal is to repurpose
a hundred thousand linens.
And I just- I cannot wait
to see what's to come.
- I love how inspiring you are.
(audience applauds)
I really want to,
I want to do a whole show on
just sustainable life tips.
I think that's so incredibly innovative,
I think it's needed and necessary.
Thank you so much, Vivian,
for sharing your time
and your innovation with us.
(audience cheers)
Good luck in college!
I'm liking your posts right now.
That's not all though.
- [Vivian] Thank you!
- Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
the go to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show",
thinks what you're doing
is as inspiring as we do.
In recognition,
they'll be using their
Frixion Erasable pen
to write you a check for a grand.
How's a thousand dollars sound?
(audience cheers)